[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
we're nearing the end of the week
[Music]
we get to say the words
supreme
court justice
katanji brown jackson
even though
there's a bunch of cry baby republicans
who don't want to say it they even
those crybabies
walked out of the senate
when she got the vote
can you imagine
being so heartbroken as a white wrinkly
old ball sack of a united states center
that a black woman would be nominated to
the supreme court such [ __ ]
crybabies such [ __ ] crybabies
i mean they cried for weeks over this
for weeks
they cried over this
not surprising
that the uh the party the party who
wants to marry babies
would be a bunch of cry babies on the
senate floor we're gonna watch video of
them walking out
as soon as the first black woman
judge brown jackson
is confirmed on the senate floor
the one the one person
uh significant to the
to the show there the the one wrinkly
old ball sack mitt romney
actually stands and collapse he stands
and claps he has some [ __ ] honor some
[ __ ] dignity
and he stood and he clapped for the
historic moment of the first black woman
to ever be
nominated and confirmed on the senate
floor
to the united states supreme court
he stood and he clapped
this is ridiculous that that's like the
that's the [ __ ] that's the bar that
we gotta oh goddamn he stood and clapped
for an historical event that's good for
our country well [ __ ] he must be a
goddamn hero
mitt romney's a [ __ ] hero cause he
clapped
that's
it's where we're at right now i mean
jesus christ he's these [ __ ]
pedocons these republican kid diddlers
are trying to pass laws in all kinds of
states apparently there's a law going
through the state of missouri that's the
same goddamn [ __ ] that tennessee had
that's the word
i told you i've been telling you over
and over and over and over again and
i'll keep repeating myself over and over
and over and over again the pedo cons
the republican kid diddlers
the gop pedophiles
they're coming for your [ __ ] children
they're coming for them they complained
they complained that judge brown jackson
was imprisoning
child pornographers and pedophiles
while they were trying to elect one to
the united states senate and roy moore
think about that
rachel bittikoffer tweeted that this
morning and if you're not retweeting
that if you're not saying that
everywhere who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] about judge brown
jackson's qualifications at this point
we do not need to rehash this already
been already been done we did that for
two weeks she is now a supreme court
justice well she will be as soon as
she's sworn in she'll be official
but her nomination has been
certified by the senate and confirmed on
the senate floor
we don't need to debate her record
anymore
we need to debate their record
the pedo cons the ones that are trying
to marry children
these [ __ ] weirdos
they're obsessed with your kid's gender
they're obsessed with your kids
sexuality what the [ __ ] is wrong with
these people
they can't stop passing laws about
children's gender children's sexuality
and marrying them
heavy projection
coming from the pedal cons
so when you find someone that's you know
talking about judge brown jacks and i
guess in your comments and your threads
in real life i'm sure you're gonna run
into one of these
[ __ ] knuckleheads
these
bone-headed [ __ ]
who are going to say oh she she she
sentenced pedophiles to prison yeah she
sentenced pedophiles to prison federal
prison time she was locking them up
while you guys are [ __ ] passing laws
to try to marry kids
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
good friday morning
we have bone end of the week today the
poll just closed we had marjorie taylor
green rand paul and lauren bobert
speaking of
pro pedophiles marjorie taylor green
projects in a tweet
that mitt romney lisa murkowski
and susan collins are pro-pedophile
the projection is heavy
the projection is heavy when she's
running around the country with with
matte gats
on her america first pedophiles i mean
you know america first pedo contour
there you go
there's you some messaging america first
petticons
[ __ ] ridiculous rand paul is late to
the vote yesterday
at the very end of the show
we played live
that
[ __ ] scumbag mitch mcconnell
statements on the floor of the senate
which we're gonna play an interview a
little clip of an interview that he did
with jonathan swann
that [ __ ] [ __ ] box mitch mcconnell we
played his statements well i didn't let
him lie that much when he got to the
part to where he's like okay now i'm
gonna trudge out all the lies
i cut him off and then we listened to
chuck schumer give his statement
you know of decency and historic
nature of the vote that they were about
to take
and we watched them vote a little bit
the problem was is that
rand paul must have been i don't know
taking a [ __ ] or
maybe he was nursing his wounds from his
neighbor i don't know
i don't know i don't know where the [ __ ]
he was but they were waiting on rand
paul the vote of course they were
[ __ ] waiting waiting on rand paul
we've all been waiting on rand paul to
pluck his head out of his [ __ ] ass
for years
and we will continue to wait
shoulders deep his head is up his ass
good morning to you all andrea is here
snick is here midas robin midas lisa
debbie salt from salt lake
amanda's here kathy is here
uh mj good morning nancy
uh lisa from facebook kristy from
facebook forest from facebook is here we
have some regulars patricia
jacqueline from facebook kaitlyn's here
crystal's here lacey's here linda's here
phil from facebook is here
we have oh my gosh
you guys know we broadcast every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central right here on youtube
twitter twitch go to thetonymichaels.com
follow us
on youtube that always helps us out go
subscribe over there
like comment subscribe go watch all the
videos you know get caught up if you're
not
if you're on facebook the midas touch
facebook page we now broadcast from
there the midas touch facebook page so
like us over there
and if you're on twitter retweet it
and if you're on twitch i guess twitch
it i don't know what you do on twitch
really honestly i'm still trying to
figure it out over there we're getting
figured out we're on youtube twitter
twitch and now coming to you from the
midas touch facebook page as a proud
partner mind is touch here on the tony
michaels podcast and we do two hours if
you're a new listener every single
weekday every one of them two hours you
can also download the audio on all your
favorite podcast directories
apple google even the most popular
boycotted one spotify you can go find it
over there
we're on all the directories wherever
you find your audio podcast just type in
the tony michaels podcast you will find
us download us
download the last episodes and give us a
five star review when you're over on
your favorite directory that helps us
out a lot and also like and subscribe
and share if you're on youtube do the
youtube thing
whatever it is that you do
do that
we have the bonehead of the week coming
to you in the second hour of the show
today you know every
single
every single weekday in this
excuse me every single friday every
single friday in the second hour we go
through your vote for bonehead of the
week we did we released the bonehead of
the week poll yesterday it was between
marjorie taylor green rand paul and
lauren bobert the only time that you
will ever vote for one of these [ __ ]
idiots
the only time but you
you put in your vote and it was clear
who the bonehead of the week was i
pretty much thought who it was gonna be
she i think other than the bonehead
madness bracket that we had a couple
weeks ago um marjorie taylor green is
like undefeated
and it's not surprising why her foot
green
continues to win the bonehead of the
week
not surprising at all especially after
her behavior
this week and the week before and really
probably next week too
i mean you can only guess you know
you're not at the bottom you can only
guess what
shitty [ __ ] stuff she's gonna racist
despicable deplorable [ __ ] she's gonna
do
but she tweets what's funny about this
what's funny about this
is the big news
about how [ __ ] despicable this piece
of [ __ ] is
hoof foot green
this non-working congress person from
georgia
the big news is she tweeted
that romney murkowski
and collins
are pro pedophile how did she tweet you
know she's really famous she runs around
she's like oh i got banned from twitter
i got banned from twitter i'm so i'm
such a great trumper i got banned from
twitter you know they you know some kind
of [ __ ] badge or some [ __ ]
that's because her her personal account
got [ __ ] banned not her
her official account
the rep account the congressperson
account here's how we can get that that
account ban to get her the [ __ ] off
twitter messaging folks 2022 midterms
are coming up she has to run
so let's get some messaging out there
let's do this messaging thing
let's do it let's get into the ring and
let's fight with these [ __ ] i mean how
would you like how would you like to
make sure
that in the senate in the senate when
two more seats come available between
now and the end of joe biden's term that
we get all these white wrinkly
nut sacks these cry baby little [ __ ]
republicans these pedocons in the senate
these kid diddlers
how about we
make sure that we have enough senators
to just to just let them walk out every
time
every time we have a supreme court
justice confirmed on the senate floor
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them
let's do that
you know how we do that you know how we
do that
we go out and we vote
and not just like mark the ballot i mean
you gotta you gotta go to the primary
you gotta you gotta pick out your
candidate you gotta help your candidate
in your district or in your state
whoever it is
your governor your state legislator your
state senator
your your community school board members
you got to help all these people who are
pro-democracy
whether that's making phone calls text
messaging trying to get yard signed
whatever the case may be knocking on
doors that's a huge one
we gotta get involved in democracy now
right now and messaging is key
when you're talking to people messaging
is key
it's gonna be the thing so listen up
every single weekday two hours a day we
give you the messaging that you need to
go out there and fight the
the fight for pro-democracy
right here on the tony michaels podcast
right here every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific youtube
twitter twitch two hours
every single day brent says donate
donate yeah you gotta donate money
i know that's it and it doesn't have to
be a lot
you just you gotta get it because it
costs money
it costs money for postcards it costs
money for phone calls it costs money for
text messaging it costs money to go
knock doors
it costs money for yard signs and merch
and all that kind of good stuff
filing fees all the things that they
have to do all the things that they have
to do
so give your time your energy and a
little bit of your money
that's what you can do for your
democracy so go out there and do that
but the most important thing the most
important thing
is to fight this fight where they're
fighting right
fight it where they're fighting
you know
everyone's like ah democrats are
horrible at messaging liberals are
horrible at messaging well there's a
reason for that
there's a reason for that there's a
reason why we never get the messaging
correct because we're always worried
about a line item in a bill that doesn't
exist
somewhere in the head of a politician
who wants to be
a liberal senator or a liberal congress
person right there's a line item in a
bill somewhere that exists in someone's
mind
well the only way to get those line
items in an office
for a congress person
in washington so that line item ends up
in a committee bill because that's what
you got to do you got to get a bill into
committee with that line item in it that
you want
that you're fighting for
so
if that line item has to be there well
you gotta do the things to get that line
item in the bill
and that means you gotta get elected you
gotta elect the person who has that line
item in mind
that's right
if they have the line item in mind you
gotta get them in that office so they
can get that line item in that bill
whatever it is
or line items or bills in general
let me tell you something
talking to people about a line item in a
bill is not going to convince them
to vote for anybody
nope not going to
it's not gonna do it
or a bill in general cancel student debt
you know we hear liberals doing this
[ __ ]
i'm not against canceling student debt
not against it not at all you know what
you know what it's it's gonna kill your
election you know what's going to kill
your election continue to focus on those
that phrase
that's a dumb [ __ ] phrase that's a
dumb [ __ ] message
you know how many people who are willing
to vote pro-democracy that hate when you
say that that may that may not go to the
polls because your messaging is off
so stop stop it
hey
you can want that you should vote you
should vote for a candidate who wants to
do something in this country about
student debt you should do that
you should go vote for him
but you know what
if you don't get the messaging right if
you don't do the politics right if you
don't do that part right and get your
candidate who you want to do something
about student debt they'll legitimately
genuinely do something about student
debt
their hearts in it
if you don't get the messaging right
you'll get a republican who's sitting in
that same office you think a republican
is going to do a goddamn thing about
student debt [ __ ] no
you know what they're going to
concentrate on marrying little babies
that's what they're going to do they're
gonna pass bills where they can marry
children
that's what they'll do
they'll pass bills to sexualize your
kid's gender in schools
banned books
scary books scary books
that make you think and educate you
that's what they're going to do
so you got it you got to fight there
because they'll win doing that
because the crazies the wackadoos in
this country
want them to
the tail is wagging the dog folks
the tail is wagging the dog
on the republican side the pedo cons
have taken over
the gop
the the gross old pedophiles
i don't doubt me
don't doubt me
you just look several years ago
they wanted to put
judge roy moore
a known unknown
chomo
a known pedophile openly admitting it
it's not like this guy was caught he
would say it out loud yeah you goddamn
right i liked him teenage girls he was
going in malls and diddling little
teenage girls
and they're trying to pass laws
in states
to make it legal to marry
so roy judge roy moore can go to the
mall and find him a bride
think about it think about it that's who
you want to make your your decision on
canceling student debt
so anyone out there who approaches you
and says i want to cancel student debt
you say great
would you rather have would you rather
have
a pedo con a republican
who wants to sexualize your children's
gender
who wants to have legal pedo pedophilia
in child brides and child marriage or
would you rather have a reasonable
person
let's do that let's do that do you want
do you want do you want a pedocon a
republican kid diddler in charge of your
gas prices
do you want do you want
republican pedophiles who are trying to
marry little girls
in charge of your economy
is that what you want
do you want someone who's trying to
sexualize your child's gender in a
school
focused and obsessed with their
genitalia in a bathroom
to make decisions on education
that's what you want
what you do
that's how we get student debt canceled
folks
that's how
you're like oh stand around tony how do
we get student debt canceled i don't
know get people who were [ __ ]
canceled elected that's how
that's how
don't elect [ __ ] pedophiles
republican kid diddlers the pedocons to
office
elect a pro-democracy person who wants
equality for all who wants equity who
wants to make sure the economy works for
everyone
including minimum wage student debt
k through 12 education
they want to st
pro-democracy people want children to
start school at the age of three instead
of five
republicans want to marry them at three
instead of 18.
got it you see the difference
do you see the difference
while katangi brown jackson was locking
up pedophiles in prison
the republicans were trying to install
roy moore a pedophile into the united
states senate
that's
that's how you cancel student debt
right there
that's how you do it
you get people who are willing to cancel
student [ __ ] debt
in office
and how you do that is you win elections
you win elections
and you go after them you put on your
[ __ ] boxing gloves you get in the
ring and you fight them that's how you
do it messaging
everyone's complaining about democrat
messaging and no one wants to do
anything about it well we're gonna
[ __ ] do something about it that's
what we're gonna do pro-democracy people
so if you're if you're listening out
there and you're hearing the stuff i'm
saying you're like hell yeah we want the
democrats to fight the good fight and
get the message and get elected so we
can have [ __ ] like a decent wage we
don't want to go bankrupt because we
have a medical bill we want good
education for our kids starting at three
we don't want [ __ ] mountains of
college debt on our [ __ ] adults who
are trying to enter the economy and
speaking of that we want a damn good
economy we want to lower taxes on the
middle class and the poor and [ __ ]
eat the rich tax the [ __ ] out of them
and what you have to do
is the messaging
that's what you gotta do you gotta win
elections
so let's do that
so come here every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch now on the midas touch facebook
page we're gonna beat this drum two
hours a day every single weekday every
week we're not gonna stop
and it's not just gonna start you know a
couple months before the midterm today
today
right now
so tune in
and go find us on all the podcast
directories
apple spotify google download give us a
five star review
coming up in the second hour we're
almost to the bottom of the first hour
coming up on the second hour we have
gabe sanchez my co-host and executive
producer is going to join us
to go over bonehead of the week
but before that
before that we want to round up the
tweety tweets and attorney trends
because that's the other thing we do
here on the donate michael's podcast is
we round up all the tweety tweets and
attorney trends for the [ __ ] list
roundup to make sure you know the news
you see it you we do not look away here
we look at all the stuff that needs to
be looked at all the stuff that's
pertinent to messaging all the stuff
that's pertinent to winning elections
and boy
boy do i have some footage to show you
from twitter today so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome back
to the tony michaels podcast we have
reached the part of the show where it's
the shitless roundup
kelly says
i listen to this podcast first and tony
looks nothing like i thought
he would
that's that's amazing it's amazing i i
hope i'm hope i hope i'm better looking
than what you thought
[Laughter]
welcome kelly to the podcast you guys
know that we're uh we're on youtube and
we have super chat and all of you guys
when i go to the youtube but if you go
to youtube and you chat you can you can
buy a super sticker you can super chat
to support the show we appreciate all
all the support that you give us here at
the tony michaels podcast it helps us
with the production it helps us keep it
running every single day so don't be shy
come in give us a super chat super
sticker i'll pull you up
on the screen we like to talk to you
guys as we're going as we're going
now sometimes it's just me so i'm trying
to keep track of the chat of who's
talking to who and then who's having an
inner chat conversation but who's
asking questions
so maybe we should come up with some
kind of code like you put some kind of
maybe like a star emoji or something so
i know uh hey
hey
i'm talking to you tony i'm talking to
you maybe that's what we'll do we'll put
if you put a star in front of your
question or or your comment i'll know
you're talking
i know you're talking to me oh kelly
thank you very much
you're adorable oh
make me blush
make me blush make me blush
thank you very much for joining us now
here's here's brent
dollars democrats deliver flip
washington's third yeah we got we gotta
make sure in washington's third that
that uh that america first nazi joe kent
doesn't get in
you know he's he's one of these steve
bannon trader tv marjorie taylor green
matt getz pedocon types you know these
republican kid diddlers he's one of
those he loves oh he loves him some mad
gats oh he he's in love with matt guess
i'm sure he's ven mode matt gets on a
daily
they're always on the venmos
i'm sure i mean he loves him a lot matt
gats i mean he's
i like
you know got a bromance going
i can only imagine
what they said in private
or what's on their venmo accounts okay
what's on that laptop joe kids joe
kent's venmo
i want to see joe cants venmo all right
let's go to the to the timeline
um
uh you know that uh tim scott did you
know tim scott
voted
against the very first black woman to be
nominated
to the supreme court
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] tim scott i
said uncle tim scott fixed it [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
jason from the the good liars post this
picture oh man that's
it looks i don't i think he's in an
airport yeah he says he says sometimes
when your flight is delayed five hours
you'll run into a spineless coward
eating a tuna sandwich
ah
so apparently paul ryan likes to eat
tuna sandwiches at the [ __ ] airport
oh jesus and it got paul i think this is
the tweet that got paul ryan trending he
is trending today
i think this is the one
this is the one
that got him trending
thanks jason for the uh
for the photo the the selfie there in
the airport oh my god
okay
oh here we go here we go
here is uh here's rachel bitte coffer
you guys know we have doc on the show
every once in a while and she's a fan
favorite here on the tony michaels
podcast
and there's a reason why she's a fan
favorite because she [ __ ] knows
messaging and she is not scared doesn't
give two [ __ ] she's gonna go after
these these pedo con republican kid
diddlers she's gonna go after him and
it's time it's time to take our country
back away from these [ __ ] weirdos who
are trying to pass laws that sexualize
our kids gender and they want to marry
our kids
it's time rachel says i'm old enough to
remember when republicans fought really
hard to install a serial ch child
molester into the united states senate
roy moore 90 of alabama republicans
voted for him 90
no wonder they want to pass merry little
kids laws it's
for them
i said yesterday
i said yesterday
yesterday i said this
can you imagine
can you even [ __ ] imagine
if there was a woman in her 30s 40s or
50s trying to marry a 10 year old boy
these people trying to pass these these
child wedding laws
these child bride laws because that's
what they are as child bride laws can
you even [ __ ] imagine they would lose
these pedo cons would lose their [ __ ]
minds
if a woman
an
older woman tried to marry a little boy
and take away his manhood take away the
possibility of that little boy growing
up to be a man
and being in power so that he could have
at least three or four child brides
you're taking it all away from him when
you marry a 12 year old boy that's what
they would say
that's how they would view it because
this has nothing to do with anything but
white powerful men wanting to marry
little girls
that's what it is they want to say oh it
has to do with gay marriage and all
[ __ ] bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
rich
powerful white men want to marry little
girls
that's what they want
doubt me go ahead
go ahead and doubt me and don't go vote
and do that thing see what happens
joe here says in florida kids can't say
gay
but in tennessee they can say i do
republicans
oh my god
this is
we're going to continue
with this and you can't let up you can't
let up because they tried to amend the
they tried to amend the law
in uh
in tennessee where they added the agent
18 because they're like oh no we got
caught they think we're pedophiles
we've been caught darryl we need to
change the law
so they tried to change it we're like no
no no no [ __ ]
nope nope nope we already seen you we
know you're a pedophile we know what you
were trying to do now you can't just go
back and change that [ __ ]
act like you're not into marrying little
girls that's not gonna happen we know
what you were trying to do roy moore jr
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
they tried to change it but they're
passing they're writing these laws in
other states
they're writing these laws in other
states folks
it's it i'm telling you this is not the
last stand of this
these old white republican men trying to
marry these little girls
speaking of all right white despicable
republican men defending putin here you
go here's more war crimes this morning
we got a story from ukraine i think i'm
going to say i'm probably going to
butcher this uh town name
uh
krama chromatrosk i i don't know i don't
know taurus
karma
i don't know ukrainian town it's a train
station there was there it was full of
civilians
waiting to get on the train to evacuate
they were struck with a ballistic
missile killing 30 and injuring at least
100 people
it's a deliberate slaughter
it's war crimes these republicans like
josh hawley and i'm going to show you
the video brian chats from from hawaii
just absolutely [ __ ] eviscerating
josh holly
but you can see this picture do not look
away folks
do not look away
those big wet spots
that's where innocent ukrainians were
[ __ ] murdered and slaughtered
by putin and his russian army
war currents
don't look away
do not
look away
and let me tell you something let me
tell you something
trump thinks this guy's a genius
he thinks this is a genius thing this is
genius i mean look how putin is is doing
a real estate deal by murdering innocent
women and children
and anyone anyone out there any [ __ ]
[ __ ]
who is supporting the pedocon trump
republican kid diddlers
is in support of this
genocide murder
and you should be telling them this to
their [ __ ] face save this picture on
your phone
if you have if you have family members
out there who are like ally or you're
you're
you're
blowing it all out of proportion this
ukrainian thing [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we are
not
vladimir putin is committing genocide in
ukraine
for his fight against democracy
and trump thinks he's a genius so much
so that trump wants his help winning in
2022
and winning in 2020
four
doubt me
and anyone who supports these vile
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
are capitulators
to the murder and the genocide that's
happening in ukraine
it's gross
it's disgusting it's despicable
and hillary clinton was correct they're
[ __ ] deplorable
[ __ ] deplorable
okay we're getting to the uh speaking of
ukrainians
being murdered
and republicans
on the side of vladimir putin
here's senator brian schatz of hawaii
absolutely eviscerating josh hawley
this is [ __ ] perfect and this is the
messaging that i've been talking about
we have to continue exactly the [ __ ] he
says here
he could have brought his floor charts
out here
and get given a withering speech about
what all of the things let's go back he
could have brought his floor charts out
here
and gave given a withering speech about
what all of the things that he thought
went wrong
but he's doing a very specific thing he
is damaging the department of defense we
have senior dod leaders
we have the armed services committee
coming to us and saying
i don't know what to tell him
i don't know how to satisfy him but he
is blocking the staffing of the senior
leadership at the department of defense
and this comes from a guy who raised his
fist
in solidarity with the insurrectionists
and this comes from a guy who before the
russian invasion suggested that maybe it
would be wise for zielinski
to make a few concessions about ukraine
and their willingness to join nato this
comes from a guy who just about a month
ago voted against ukraine aid he's
saying it's going too slow he voted no
he voted no on ukraine aid and now he
has the gall to say it's going too slow
and this final insult
is that until what secretary austin
resigns
that's not a serious request
people used to come to me during the
trump administration all the time do you
think trump should resign do you think
tillerson should that's a stupid of
course i think all the people i disagree
with should quit their jobs and be
replaced with people i love of course i
think they should all resign that's not
how this world works
that is not a
reasonable request from a united states
senator that until the secretary of
defense quits his job i'm going to block
all of his nominees that's preposterous
and coming from a person who exonerated
donald trump for extorting zielinski for
withholding lethal aid
they withheld lethal aid
until
unless
zielinski would release false smears
against joe biden's son and then he
voted to exonerate president trump for
this and so spare me
the new solidarity with the ukrainians
and with the free world because this
man's record is exactly the opposite
this man josh hawley is who he's
speaking about here i said you want to
see a dead body
because
uh brian
schatz absolutely murders josh holly
here
murders him at every single point at
every single
uh
every single pro putin policy that josh
hawley has had
not only does josh holly uh love
vladimir putin vladimir putin loves josh
holly for all of this loves him oh they
he [ __ ] vladimir putin is a josh
hawley fan
he's a josh hawley fan imagine imagine a
man who is a a murderous dictator who's
trying to leak into another another
sovereign state another sovereign
country that isn't his
and try to take over and become the
ruler there just like josh hawley is
doesn't live in missouri and came into
missouri and is the senator represents
us as senator he was the [ __ ]
attorney general and didn't live in
missouri
josh hawley was the attorney general of
the state of missouri didn't even live
here
he had he had to rent a house
so that he could come live here
and then he ran for senate used his
sister's address
down in southwest missouri
and he lives in virginia he doesn't even
live in missouri [ __ ] that guy
and i hope that the
senator schatz here continues
continues
to bury him uh adam said here about this
this clip brian chat's telling josh
holly to go [ __ ] himself is worth a
watch hell it's worth more than one
watch you should watch it four or five
times
learn how to
how to bang up these fascist
these pro putin pedo con fascists
okay we're gonna get to um
the bonehead of the week
and i think we have um several um
people maybe some from tennessee that
are gonna be on the alpha cuck and
dishonorable mention
but it's not just it's not just the
pedophilia bills the the ridiculousness
that's coming out of the republicans in
tennessee even republicans in tennessee
who are who are a pro pedophile bill um
are anti this ivermectin bill apparently
they have an ivermectin bill or some
[ __ ] i don't know [ __ ]
listen to this clip from tennessee
experts that we had testifying on this
may be spreading more misinformation
than actually maybe
you goddamn right they are first large
best controlled study on avermectin came
out it's going to be published in the
new england journal medicine the most
prestigious medical journal of the world
there's no sign of any benefit from
mybermectin this is the company that
could have benefited tens of billions of
dollars and i'm going to read this
straight off their website no scientific
basis for a potential therapeutic effect
against cope and a concerning lack of
safety data in the majority of studies
maybe i do have a pro-science bias but i
did want to stand and express my
concerns the evidence is that this
doesn't work of course it is
there is never been evidence that i ever
made
here we go with that and ivor
here's here's uh the senator janice
bowling
republican
from tulahoma district 16.
what a [ __ ] bonehead she is
listen to this [ __ ] moran it was
discovered to be very affected my
husband and i both contracted omicron so
we immediately began our treatment it
says janice is doing her own studies
y'all vibram
it was very effective it wasn't a
placebo and i appreciate this
legislation ivermectin saved many many
lives i think it does help and i think
it is reasonable this is ridiculous here
is senator joey hensley another [ __ ]
republican of course another another
[ __ ] pedocon
who believes that hey you know what
child
child brides oh there's nothing wrong
with that [ __ ] why wouldn't they believe
that ivermectin is the cure for covet
why wouldn't they at this point and
beneficial to make it available let's be
clear let's be clear all the ivermectin
horse pace goblin spread necks out there
they're trying to run for office they're
winning offices they have they have
power and our state legislators our
counties our school boards our congress
our u.s senate and they're all part of
this pedo con
republican kid diddler ring for the
patients that want it it's a lot safer
to go to your pharmacist and let him
tell you how much i expected to take oh
i'm going to go to the co-op and guess
what size horse you are high oh jesus
christ
and the republicans pass it anyways
even with the [ __ ] nonsense and this
is tennessee holler now thank you
tennessee holler for for posting this
video if you want to see some of the
ridiculous stuff that is going on in
tennessee uh go follow tennessee holler
and they will keep you
up to speed on some of the crazy ass
[ __ ] i tweeted this morning putin is a
despicable piece of [ __ ]
anyone and i do mean anyone who stands
with that [ __ ] trash is culpable for
genocide here's looking at you pedo cons
[ __ ]
horse goblin pieces of [ __ ] okay
um there's a few and here's the brian
chance video again let's see i think i
had a couple more things i wanted to uh
to get to today
oh here we go uh mayo is mayo out there
listening she's usually on twitch
listening mayo says democracy one today
may i was talking about the nomination
and the confirmation of judge
katangi brown jackson now soon to be
sworn in
as
justice
katangi brown jackson speaking of
justice contangie brown jackson here is
a video
and gates's breaking republican
strategist
involved in the contagion brown jackson
hearing gives an interview so here's
here's an interview apparently from a
republican strategist let's let's listen
in on this this interview hold it just
like this
i'm what you consider a republican
strategist for scotus nominee hearings i
have a very particular set of skills
that's a quote from the movie taken do
you guys know lee anyway i'm the guy you
call when you struggle to make an
argument against a nominee with these
hearings you really got to derail them
as much as possible you know you got to
use buzzwords like cancel culture
religion porn crt
woman i had josh hawley go to pound town
on porn i mean
yeah he's a bit obsessed with porn but
you got the job done lindsey graham he's
not even religious but i had him up
there like a self-righteous pastor did
you see when ted cruz waved around the
anti-racist baby book yeah that was all
me wait wait that book is now a number
one seller on amazon well i guess
republicans will want to cancel amazon
now honestly she's more qualified than
any current justice but uh
you didn't hear that from me the
republicans have no legitimate reason to
say no they're just uh
racist like really racist and sexist
sorry what was that she was confirmed oh
tucker carlson's not gonna like this
hold it just like this
i'm what you can say
i don't know who this
who this republican strategist is but
boy he's he's got a lot of information
here
[Music]
um
speaking of uh
people who make great videos gabe
sanchez is gonna join us here in just a
little bit for the breakdown of the
bonehead of the week poll
that you take every single week again
if you go
follow at tony michael's pod the cl the
poll closed this morning
go follow tony michael's pod
on twitter and you can vote every single
week for bonehead of the week
and then every single friday in the
second hour
we go through and break down the
bonehead of the week we broke break down
your vote your vote me and gabe break
down your vote
of who wins bonehead of the week we also
do dishonorable mention and alpha cup
and just to remind everyone out there
because i've seen a few comments here
asking when we play this podcast when
does it air where does it air youtube
twitter twitch go follow us on youtube
just search the tony michaels podcast on
youtube
make sure to subscribe and hit the bell
notification and comment and like down
below all that kind of good stuff
whatever you gotta say on youtube right
and join us every single weekday live
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
youtube twitter and twitch
and now coming to you from the midas
touch facebook page we are proud
partners of midas touch the tony
michaels podcast
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 center on youtube
twitter twitch
live
and then once we're done with the show
what i do is i take the audio and i put
it up on all the podcast directories
so if you don't want to look at this
beautiful face right if you just want to
hear
my beautiful beautiful voice
then you would go download it on apple
spotify google wherever you download
your podcast it is there on that
directory just search the tony michaels
podcast
and make sure you give us a good review
there five star review none of this
three star four star bad review stuff
that's not allowed at the tony michaels
podcast
we got a few trolls that went over there
and
um gave us some you know one star you
know that you know you know how these
trolls are yeah they get butt hurt that
we tell the truth here and we tell it in
a way that comes right at them so they
they get a little they get a little
upset and they go give me bad reviews or
whatever
so go offset some of the troll reviews
give us some good reviews over there
five star good reviews
and that would help out the show a lot
so thank you for joining us live here on
youtube twitter twitch and now from the
midas touch facebook page you guys can
always comment i'll try to bring you in
and if you go to the the youtube chat
the youtube chat
is the place to be folks because then
you can do a super chat
did it do i guess that's the maybe the
noise i should have maybe i should have
a noise
super chat
and you can also do a super sticker to
support the show
it's fantastic so thank you very much
thank you very much for supporting the
show thanks you for coming watch us and
continue to listen every single weekday
for two hours monday through friday
do that and we'll get this messaging
we'll get this messaging down
folks
we'll teach you how to message and get
out there
and win this midterm 2022
make sure we remain a democracy
we do not want these pedocons in charge
we do not want these republican kid
diddlers
in charge of education gas prices the
economy healthcare do you want a bunch
of [ __ ] people who want to marry
children in charge of anything
i can't think of one goddamn thing that
i'd let someone who wants to marry a
little girl
in charge of something can you not a
[ __ ] goddamn thing
i'd put them in charge of
nope maybe mopping the floors on a
federal prison
that that might be it
might be it just mopping the floors at a
federal prison is about the only thing
that i put one of these chomos these
pedo cons these republican kid diddlers
in charge of that's probably it
[ __ ] weirdos
sexualizing kids gender
sexualizing the classroom of these
children
what are you doing you weirdos
passing laws not just in tennessee folks
not just in tennessee now apparently
missouri has their own child bride law
they're trying to marry little kids in
missouri now
kathy thank you for the super sticker
thank you very much kathy you are here
almost every single day actually i think
you're here almost every it is every day
monday through friday thank you kathy
for listening and thank you for your
support thank you for the super sticker
all right let's let's go to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends here
now that we've been to the timeline you
guys know that's kind of how i do it
go through the timeline first you know
that's the important stuff the stuff
the stuff that i have tweeted
that's that's that's kind of how i i
figured this show like
if you go to my page like in the morning
and you're like oh what's tony going to
talk about today you'll probably know
number one you can go to the trends but
but you can also go to my timeline
you're like oh he's going to talk about
this video he's retweeted this video
he's surely going to talk about this one
oh he's definitely going to talk about
this
because i'm retweeting stuff so i
remembered to talk about it
it really isn't a rocket science it's
just
just how it turns out so if you're
listening out there you know if you're
listening on the the podcast directories
know
that uh every once in a while you should
head over head over to youtube or or
twitch or twitter or now the minus touch
facebook page and take a look at what
we're looking at
not just what we're talking about
um let's see dollywood is trending
all of a sudden dollywood started to
trend here
i didn't have that on my list
why is dollywood trending i'm sure it's
because dolly parton is a badass
dolly parton is probably a badass
um so
apparently
it looks like here readers discuss an
article online
magazine the federalist oh god i'm sure
it's just riveting i'm sure the
federalist is just riveting
title cancer your disney vacation and go
to dollywood instead do they have any
idea who dolly barton is dolly parton
dolly parton definitely would not be on
the side of ron desantis
i would imagine if you if you question
sat down dolly barton knowing that she's
a decent human being and such a badass
and such a badass i i would almost bet
i would almost bet that dolly parton
would be would be diametrically opposed
to anything almost anything that ron
desantis said
because ron desantis is a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and dolly parton is it is not only a
great singer a great performer one of
the best artists of our time she's a
philanthropist and she is a fantastic
and one of the best human beings that we
have in this country
that that's it
full stop if you don't like it [ __ ] you
you can stop watching this show
dolly parton tweets here
um
what is she saying this is this morning
i know there are some folks who have
been affected and i hope that you will
join me in saying and pray for them
during this time i've also remained in
touch with my people at dollywood who
assured me everything is okay there
what happened what happened what
happened is this this morning oh this is
march 31st sorry this is an old tweet
um but uh
but it is dolly pulling up because of
dollywood is trending
at this story these people should go to
dollywood of course lincoln project here
says who's gonna tell them
like who's gonna tell them
who's gonna tell them that
that dolly parton
is against the don't say gay bill i
don't i don't have to guess
like i don't even need dolly parton to
say it out loud
on video for me to know for me to know
that dolly parton is against
vehemently against the don't say gay
bill
don't even need i don't even need
evidence i really don't uh bo the fifth
column says don't go to disney they're
woke instead go to checks notes
notoriously
lgbtq friendly pro vaccine pro for
workers unions and books buying banned
books for libraries dollywood for [ __ ]
sake if she wasn't so sweet and polite
she'd been massed up in portland
oh my god
oh these people really are [ __ ] dumb
they really are [ __ ] dumb
uh pro tip
beau says country music icons are
generally woke as [ __ ] and that's the
truth
that's the truth
don't don't doubt it bo is right here
this is correct
this this tweet here is [ __ ] correct
do you guys remember back in the 1990s
there was this country music artist his
name was um
trying to remember this guy's name he
was a little popular i think his name
was uh brooks garth or garth brooks
something like that
something like that i think it was garth
brooks i think that was the guy's name
you know he was kind of famous
he was famous for being on the side of
the lgbt community in the 90s
in the 90s
now garth brooks is no liberal bastion
or anything he's not some [ __ ]
crazy liberal socialist
he's just like a decent human being that
thinks other humans should have their
dignity and treated like a human being
because most artists most people who
create art are woke as [ __ ] quote
unquote woke as [ __ ]
these people really are stupid
i can't believe that they think dolly
parton
would be for the don't say gay bill you
people really are [ __ ] dumb
okay let's move on
i'm really disappointed that that didn't
make it into my uh
into my description there um here is the
uh the thread
for
um
the atrocity that happened at the train
station in ukraine where 30 people have
lost their lives and 100 have been
killed um
it looks like they're now that now looks
like 50 killed
maybe the number 50 killed at a railroad
station and um i'm not even try the name
ukraine russia fired a missile at a
facility full of civilians getting
evacuated from the war just because it
can and because we won't we don't have
enough means to make russia stop firing
missiles against us
this is sad it's a war crime
and anyone who has ever stood with putin
at any point tucker carlson fox news
josh hawley
senator ted cruz
donald trump and anyone anyone
anyone
and here is a video i'm gonna retweet
this i'm not gonna pull this video up
too tight
here um just because it shows dead
bodies
that's right the video shows dead bodies
i just retweeted it so if you want to go
to my timeline you can see it here's the
picture we pulled up earlier after the
bodies had been removed
it's time folks
it's time for us to get the messaging
straight because here's the rub can you
even [ __ ] imagine can you even
[ __ ] imagine a pro putin pedo cons
republican kid dealers get control of
the senate and the congress
and they put donald trump a a putin
sycophant
a putin deep throater
a kid diddler himself
can you imagine if he becomes the
speaker of the house that's what they
want
they're giving us this race in 2022
they're giving it to us
they've exposed who they are they they
don't keep the quiet part quiet anymore
they say the quiet part out loud and
they're going to continue
it's [ __ ] disgusting it's gross and
we should do something about it and what
you do about it is you message
and you electioneer
and you continue and continue and
continue to pound the drum
about how these pedophiles these putin
pedophiles
the petticons that the republican kid
diddlers are
want to take over our government and
have control and let putin run rampant
in ukraine and let pro-putin people be
in charge of our country
pedo pro putin petticons being in charge
being in charge of our economy being in
charge of our gas prices
being in charge of our supply chains
[ __ ] you you're not getting your pro
putin pedo con hands on my child's
education
you're not getting your pro putin
pedophile hands
on our health care
you don't get to have it
so go message now we're at the top of
the hour we're going to bring in um gabe
sanchez here uh very soon
um and we're going to do bonehead of the
week we're gonna break down your
your vote
for bonehead of the week so let's let's
go to a quick break
we'll be right back
after these messages when we come back
in the second hour we will soon
we will soon be to the bone head of the
week stick around right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one in your absence i
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and i even seen my
cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the journey michael's podcast
[Music]
coming to you live every single weekday
monday through friday today is happy
friday day because we are in the second
hour and you know what happens in the
second hour we go to
bonehead of the week
and let's see we may or may not let's
see if we can get his microphone you
know we got a co-host and he's always
he's always he's always here but
sometimes he just can't get his
microphone working gabe do you get your
you get your mic working this morning
i do oh
folks he got his microphone working this
is a good day we have all gonna be a
real good show
i don't know i just you know i just i'm
just working you know i'm working with
the new personality okay
i got you bone end of the week um
it was really difficult this week
because there was like a [ __ ] ton of
republicans even republicans that people
didn't know from tennessee to put on yes
they really put themselves out there
right right but the one the one you know
of course she's
i'm real surprised still right by the
bonehead madness of marjorie taylor
green
i'm really surprised but i thought she
was gonna take it all i know i know so
we'll get to the bone end of the week
but the one thing i want to um
i want to go to
the did it do let's see if i can go to
my profile here i think there's one
thing i want to ask you about here
um where is it where is it well well i i
i'm
trying to um
it may
where what what is it i i forgot
i'm forgetting get calm down calm down
oh here it is yes yes this is uh
we played this video and this is one of
the reasons why we have some of these
bonehead of the weeks on the poll
who is this guy where did you find this
guy uh i it was uh you know i i don't
know if anyone's seen dark money just
the first one but it looks like they're
filming i mean look at the the date on
the slate right here says 4 7 22. so it
looks like they were doing an interview
this was happening real time and then
someone got hold of the footage and they
released it oh it's i see i see this
show the documentary hasn't even come
out because it said like dark money too
even darker money you know i see because
well yeah because it sounds like an
action movie honestly yeah well there's
the there's the uh
the title screen right
dark money to even darker money
but but this person and in this in this
video we played it earlier but the did
this person video yeah he mentions um
um what's what's the movie he mentions
um let's see here
what is oh yeah taken taken
yeah he quotes a movie taken yeah and
then you know he wants to know if they
know liam neeson neil i mean i guess you
know that's a fair assumption they're in
the movie industry right i mean i guess
well right if you have if you have like
a video camera and one of those snappy
things what's that called it's called
the slate it's called it's called the
slime
the snippy thing the snappy thing who
else knows that besides you know people
in the industry uh
that's why he probably asked do you know
liam yeah that's probably why he's like
oh if you got a camera and a snappy
thing then surely you know i wouldn't be
surprised if he thought this like he was
actually uh involved in a new liam
neeson movie because i mean like money
too right right
sounds like a could be a liam neeson
movie wasn't there a taken two there was
a taken two and it taken three taken
three uh-huh
she got took three times three
this sounds like this sounds like a
republican tennessee republican bill we
didn't it sounds like a dream come true
honestly
i don't think they've made it taken four
oh okay uh but if i would like to assume
the four would be the a in the taken
that should be good you know that's just
like my initial branding kind of
maybe maybe uh uh roy moore will star
and take him forward oh yeah i'm sure a
lot of those guys who make cameos like
you know dudes in like a back
smoke-filled room right you know
it's probably eyes wide shut i don't
know you know
yeah probably same place as uh uh
madison cawthorne yeah probably well
yeah so you think he's he's definitely a
pedocon for sure oh for sure for sure a
pentagon one of these republican kid
diddlers for sure yeah uh mj mj thank
you very much uh for the super chat and
she couldn't love y'all more let's say
democracy i think she's talking to
everyone in the chat thank you very much
mj thank you thank you very much for the
support so let's let's do this let's get
to
um bone head of the week let's see if we
can let's see the transition we can make
here on three one two three
bone end of the week look at that
you know you know we gotta get the art
department you know here's the thing i
am literally working on that right now
but if i look at it
i have to figure out you know what the
change is happening here right so i got
the banner that would say like follow us
i mean this looks good this looks good
you know the transition could be more
seamless you know right right right but
then i gotta i got still gotta put the
logo on the bottom right corner and i
gotta put the banner and i literally
have it up on my screen right now and i
was
just trying to figure just trying to
figure out how to you know make it work
speaking of the art department let's
let's play the intro and then let's get
to bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to bone head of the week
this
this week's edition every friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
you know we air
every single weekday monday through
friday but on friday we do this special
segment bone end of the week where you
guys go over to at tonymichaelspod on
twitter
take your vote for bonehead of the week
and then me and gabe break it down here
right here on the second hour of the
tony michaels podcast in the segment
called bonehead of the week and gabe we
have some really
i mean these are normal boneheads i mean
i don't i don't even know how many times
like well we really need to have like a
record thing going like how many times
these people will be you know i'm going
to i hear it next yeah
it'll just be like mtg it'll be right
lauren beaubert i have to go we have to
go back through the footage right to
figure out how many times because here's
here's our here's our nominees for the
week we have a representative if you uh
loosely uh defined marjorie taylor green
uh senator rand paul not his neighbor
ran actual actually rand ball yeah and
then lauren of bobo
for the bonehead of the week that you
guys made your vote for
you guys made your vote for this week
and guess who won
you know again i want to go back to
all three of these are like easily
easily the bonehead of the week right
like i mean it's not difficult to see
why or how these three would become
bonehead of the week right
when you have these three on there but
it really was no competition yes like at
all
right yeah marjorie taylor green headed
out front and stayed out front the
entire time was like 70
yeah
right is that is that the is that
no it's like a
it's like i i don't know it's you know
it's not quite a car it's not quite an
engine you know i don't know it's just
like
you know it's just like her taking off
ahead of the rest of the group you know
well we we have some uh special um and
dishonorable mention and alpha cook
which the dishonorable mention will not
surprise you either um the alpha cuck
it's not surprising but i don't think we
really know who this person is but let's
start
with the the ultimate loser and bonehead
beaubert here uh lauren why did we have
her
on the bonehead of the week pull well
she had a moment
this week where she was talking to um
let me let me look it up really quick
she was talking to someone during a it
was a there's like a little hearing that
was being done where she was asking
questions with some other colleagues
there was only like five people that
were there and one person answering i
didn't know if it i didn't know if it
was the uh mickey mouse thing or not
no well i mean look we could we could
throw that in there let me let me show
let me show the audience here um
because i believe i still have yeah i
just wait no no let's see um
see if i can find it here but i was at
the mickey mouse thing because she
tweeted uh mickey mouse and a lot of
people called her out on it right so the
reason i brought her up was because
lauren bobert kept asking the u.s health
chief if men could get pregnant
so she took a page out of
black what now what no what
she wanted to know if men could get
pregnant
and you mean like a person without a
uterus is it what you think yeah yeah
yeah she wants them to define to be like
who are these people these you know the
man versus woman who can get pregnant i
wanted to be like let's roll the clip of
the arnold schwarzenegger movie
uh where he does give birth right
uh top-notch film should have gotten an
oscar for sure
um
but
uh he
was like uh
what like i like what why are you asking
this question and she was like trying to
she was trying to have a gotcha moment
and it didn't really work out it was
like marsha blackburn came and it was
like what is a woman right well and then
you see someone asked josh holly this
this what is a woman oh right yeah they
had followers a woman is barefoot in the
kitchen and can get pregnant and if she
can't get pregnant then she's no longer
a will i mean he was like questioning
like he's like oh my god if if if if a
human being can't get pregnant is it a
woman like he he really did not he did
not they have a hard time uh
they don't know what a woman thinking
well they have a hard time thinking
right well that is true let's let's
let's play the clip of the mickey mouse
debacle though i actually i featured
that tweet but another quote tweet of it
on the show a couple days ago let's see
what else do we get going here
oh yes oh yes this is a great one uh
eric swalwall says
m-i-c-k-e-y because lauren bobert and
bone-headed [ __ ] she says next year the
woke disney
lobbyist will ask congress to extend
mickey mouse's trademark i think not of
course she spelled mickey m-i-c-k-y eric
swallow points out there's literally a
song that taught millions of us how to
spell it if these losers aren't weren't
dumb we'd be screwed
m-i-c-k-e-y-m-o-u-s-e
you remember the song it taught us how
to spell it
whoosh is it surprising that lauren
bobert doesn't know how to spell mickey
mouse i mean is it really some rate
sounds surprising it really isn't what's
surprising is is that when she typed in
mickey mouse on her phone and i'm not
sure i haven't checked this but i would
imagine if you type in mickey mouse on
your phone and spell checks it so even
her [ __ ] phone is stupid
i actually checked this gabe i went and
made sure that i fact checked myself you
tried to misspell it yes absolutely and
the phone said there's a [ __ ] song
that's that's literally
i i asked siri i ask alexa and that's
literally what they said they're like
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me there's a
goddamn siri just
siri responds and goes
face palm you're right right right it
really is [ __ ] dumb because like when
you start to spell out mickey mouse on
your phone right it smells it it smells
it for you so even her phone is [ __ ]
dumb even her phone is a [ __ ]
bonehead all right let's move on to uh
rand paul i don't know if anyone knows
uh why we put rand paul on uh other than
he's just a complete dumb [ __ ] i mean
yes that's an easy one but yesterday
uh and several people on this show
watched yesterday at the very end of the
show
that scumbag mitch mcconnell um came out
on the senate floor and gave his
statements about the
um the confirmation vote of katangi
brown jackson now justice brown jackson
um he gave his deplorable statements and
when he when he started the lie game
when he when he went into let me go
through
what i don't believe a
goddamn word from that guy's mouth he's
still trying to flush those documents
down his toilets that he said still
getting pissed about right right so so
mitch mcconnell i muted him and then we
had chuck schumer and we watched the
vote but when there was one vote missing
and i didn't know who it was at the time
when we were on the show i was like who
the [ __ ] is missing there's one vote
missing
right but you shouldn't have had to
guess but you didn't have to guess it
really i mean it was kind of i think you
had a tweet yesterday which is like
we're waiting for right right oh this is
right you know like literally literally
we've been waiting for him to pluck his
head out of his ass for years and years
and years and we're gonna wait a bit
longer and probably now longer still um
i mean it's not like they even needed
the vote anyway
but
you know it's
to
to hold out like you're like all right
they've got 53 you know let's call it
5346 because this dumbass doesn't like
he wants to it's like that pose that
trump had would like you've got like the
g
like the whole like global uh leaders
you know and he's like
you know just like this that's rand paul
in many ways
other than the only time he ever gets
engaged with something is when he's like
trying to take in
uh russian money right well yeah well i
mean he is he is he is a pro-putin
pedocon um but i said we have we have
been waiting on rand paul to pluck his
head out of his ass for a long time
probably going to wait a bit longer here
is the actual screenshot of what c-span
had up they actually posted even
even c-span burns rand ball like waiting
on this [ __ ] like we're waiting
this this week
yeah it's like he i guess
has to he has to give some indication
of like
uh not participating or participating in
uh yes no but the fact that he just like
you look at it and you're like okay like
we already knew leading up all 50
democrats were gonna do it and we had
three republicans who were going to vote
yes
so you already know the outcome there's
no way unless you're going to uh just
all of a sudden
persuade someone
to change their vote like it's gonna be
she's gonna be confirmed because you
guys put this rule in place when you
guys wanted to force through ac like amy
coney barrett so don't get mad when you
didn't you know you weren't able to
filibuster all his [ __ ] so i'm sorry
you guys set the rules and the precedent
we just used them but we don't actually
need your vote so the fact that you're
holding out
is so petty and childish
it makes you look like an even bigger
ass
right like you just could have been like
i vote no and that's it i said my piece
but the fact that you had to hold off
your vote and wait
well you know maybe maybe he was taking
a [ __ ] maybe he was immersing the wounds
that he still has from his neighborhood
absolutely
i don't know i don't know i mean they're
still probably he i mean you know that
neighbor we should give him a medal of
honor but here i i will tell you that um
rand paul even though it was boneheaded
for him to try to hold the vote whatever
he was trying to do whatever his
motivations were i think it was just he
wanted to get the attention right
the one person that we did not give
attention to because of it was that
uncle tim scott that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] oh god who who not only voted no on
the first black woman to become a
supreme court justice but he walked up
and did a thumbs down yeah like he made
a show
out of voting against the first black
woman which is kind of [ __ ] gross
especially when he knows she's qualified
and i believe he even put a statement
out saying that oh yeah she's qualified
and blah blah blah but it's a no vote
for me because
i'm i'm a pro putin petticon like that's
maybe the the thing that they're the ppp
right ppp hey that's pretty good maybe
they want that money get some of the ppp
money yeah well that could be that could
be uh you send me a link here let's go
back for just a second because you sent
me a link here of the uh
of the boba yeah in case anyone in case
anyone doubted me i said there's like
five people that are talking and there's
one person responding and it's the
health chief right and
he's a former congressman right yeah
and
but let's let's let's watch to start off
as a secretary of health and human
services can you define for this
committee what is a man
you're looking at one
great
so you are a man i like that
can you tell me
can she she did not expect him to say
that yeah she was like oh okay she
expected him to say like because she
expected the she wanted the definition
right right yeah right again she saw
marsha blackburn do this and then she
goes i like my beer you're right i'll do
one even i'll do one even more stupid
so she's like she's like she watches
marsha blackburn make a total fool out
of her [ __ ] self and and and she's
like you know what that was such that
was such a great clip that i really want
to look like a dumb [ __ ] yeah men get
pregnant
what what what what was that like you're
asking if men can get pregnant
so you are a man i like that
can you tell me
can men get pregnant
unless you know something i don't i
think the answer's pretty awesome
what is that
okay we gotta stop there we gotta send
it because he's like he's like
we're in it we're in a cause i don't
know what this committee hearing is
actually about like the actual subject
but he's like i'm here to actually
answer questions for the record for the
american people as the health and human
service secretary like this this more
than likely is a is a hearing about
health care right like important matter
in to american people most american
people don't want to go broke or
bankrupt because of a medical bill and
this is the person uh one of the people
that is in the administration that is
standing between uh that organization or
that that institution the health and
human services and making sure that
americans don't just go broke because of
medical bills and here he's like having
to answer questions if men can have
babies it's he's like are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me yeah sir
i'm asking you is there something you
know that i don't know that would say
that well i'm asking what you know
can men get pregnant
i'm not aware of it okay well um mr
secretary of materials coming from your
department you've referred to mothers as
as birthing persons replacing that title
with
are our mothers not persons
so so this is this is what i've said
several times is when someone asks you
out there if you're listening and
someone asked you like they're like
they're trying to get you because you're
libtard i'm gonna get you i'm gonna wrap
you up in this argument about a man and
a woman so when some dumb [ __ ] ask you
what's a woman do you know what a woman
is you say yes it's a gender that a
person identifies as right it's really
simple it's it's not complicated it's a
gender
that a person identifies as and then if
you really want to get them if you
really want to catch them you say what
gender do you identify as right and
they'll say well i identify as a man oh
okay so you understand what a man is
then it's a gender that someone
identifies as and they'll get in their
cells in the lubricant right right
no all right right exactly
right that's exactly how you do it so
just maybe we'll work you know play this
over on a loop if someone asks you
what a woman is you say it's a j or a
man either way it's a gender that a
person identifies as and then you just
follow it immediately you say what
gender do you identify as and they'll
say their gender and you say oh okay so
you understand what what a man is or a
woman whatever the case is that's how
you do it and they'll [ __ ]
hopefully they'll melt into a you know a
steamy pile it'll be like that scene
from uh raiders of the lost ark
and they open up pandora's box and their
face are just like
that's pretty much what i would imagine
would happen here we go
mothers are persons but it seems to be
more inclusive like you're trying to
include another gender in that i'm all
about inclusion congresswoman there you
go
like inclusion equality equity you know
those things you know human beings like
she tried to make a point and he was
like do you know something i don't know
are are women not persons
i like to include everyone and she's
like okay okay moving on uh like you're
you attempted to make a point that was
very poorly done
and then you just conceded
it's you know like you're just like okay
thank you like that you ate you answered
exactly what i wanted you to do and it's
like
you you realize
you didn't make a point there right like
if anything that the point that you were
thinking you were making you weren't
actually making
you know what's funny about this clip is
that lauren beaubert
thinks she's smarter
than secretary bakara that reminds me of
who's that uh
uh eric schmidt
eric schmidt yeah or ethan smith ethan
ethan schmidt eric sorry eric schmidt
from google very smart guy ethan schmidt
anti-masters club not so smart
anti-masters club that's the video
that's the video that i wanted that i
wanted to play but let's let's go let's
go to
um let's let's go we'll get to him maybe
uh in the alpha cook section let's go to
dishonorable mention for don't let me
forget about that the he-man's women is
it he-man's woman haters club is that
the club he started yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay good good good um matt gatz the uh
pedal con from from florida
um he why is he the bone or the
dishonorable mention for bonehead of the
week what what got him in this category
uh i'll pull up the clip for you but
matt gates uh decided to throw his hat
into the ring regarding this like
uh back and forth tiff joke late night
joke that was from um jimmy kimmel right
and it was all it all started with when
he's talking to marjorie taylor green is
that the great right yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
yeah so basically to set it up uh marger
taylor green sends out a tweet that says
uh romney murkowski and collins all
three of them are voting for uh kbj
they're all pro pedophiles and that's
why she's on the bone head of the week
right right that's like the main reason
yeah she got herself on there for that
tweet and some other stuff but mainly
that tweet and then
um
uh jimmy kimmel brings the tweet up on
his late night monologue and he says
where's will smith when you need him
right obviously alluding to the slap
right he didn't say
like oh you know he should do this but
he's like where's this guy when you need
him right by the way by the way
hilarious joke yeah i think i'm just
saying it yeah yeah no regardless of
what you think of the will smith chris
rock that's a great joke anyways go
ahead
so well i got this helicopter plane
thing going on oh dear yeah okay okay
all right i think it's good i think it's
gone i think it's good yeah i gotta work
with the elements here okay so then what
ends up happening is marjory taylor
green says uh attention capital police
uh i'd like to report this
as uh
as a threat against my life right which
is hilarious considering the fact that
marger taylor greene has no respect for
the capitol police who kept her and
other people at the capitol safe on
january 6th the people that she shits
all over him and eric swalwell i think
as speaking of eric swallow he pointed
out that she voted against funding the
capital police exactly and she didn't
want to give them the medal of honor she
didn't want to give them that she want
to give it to the j6 patriots she wanted
to give it to kyle rittenhouse she did
not want to give it to
uh the capitol police she didn't even
want to acknowledge
their role in saving their lives from
getting just [ __ ]
beaten down right right
so she says that uh then uh jimmy kimmel
goes uh attention police i'd like to
report a joke right she goes back and
then she comes back and says like oh
this is an attack i get all these
different things like i i'm the victim
blah blah blah of course
right and and that's where we get on to
this the fire brand matt gates podcast
you know now wait a second so you're
telling me
i just want to be clear here
that marjorie taylor green this all
starts with a tweet where she accuses
someone of being a pedophile and then
she ends up
on a podcast bitching about this with a
pedophile is that what you're saying yep
an accused sex trafficker a child sex
trafficker a pro putin pedicon oh this
is fantastic let's watch this clip here
i think this is the one isn't it this is
the one that you want me to play yeah
and by the way jimmy kimmel not only
would marjorie taylor green's husband
make quick work of you
oh so so wait a second so
matt gets his uh
natural instinct to say that jimmy
kimmel was uh was uh
threatening marjorie taylor is to
threaten him yeah this is beautiful this
is right marjorie taylor green would
make quick work of you and if you don't
believe that you could go ask the
marines that did pull ups with her at
the iowa state fair and uh my guess is
that jimmy jimmy kimmel would not last
too long if uh if he himself were
interested
in engaging in unprovoked terrible
violence uh against uh against this
congresswoman you mean you mean like uh
uh unprovoked violence like i don't know
breaking into a building and trying to
commit a cheeto dust kangaroo beating
beating the capitol police the police
officers that you called with a [ __ ]
american and confederate flag
is that the kind of is that the kind of
unprovoked violence that you're talking
about or even i mean
yeah let's talk about uh marjorie taylor
green is is
like she has a real knack for being vile
and harassing people like look at uh
david hogg right uh a school a mass
shooting at a school survivor he's now
an activist does great work you know
leading the charge in terms of reform
uh
there are videos of her harassing him on
the street other school victims she's
harassing them
by asking them questions and and
bringing up the fact of like oh it was a
hoax are you guys well yeah they're kids
crisis actors
they continue to diddle kids over and
over and over again rather it's to shame
them because they were [ __ ] victims
of a school shooting and they were there
and they were traumatized and they're
trying to do something about it they
diddle kids that way they want to diddle
kids by marrying them in tennessee and
other states they want to dittle kids by
by sexualizing their gender it's all
over the place here is this [ __ ] this
this vile piece of [ __ ] um thinking uh
think
so it starts out she tweets that uh
romney murkowski and collins are
pro-pedophile because they're voting to
confirm kbj justice kbj now and then
she's thanking up
accused pedophile of defending her
oh this is here we go yeah and they go
and do it yeah and jimmy jimmy knows it
happens and you know and and so matt i'm
really grateful for you um as as wait
wait wait wait let's let's roll that
back because matt gatz is an accused sex
child sex trafficker
he is a pro putin petticon
a republican kid diddler let's listen to
this again let's make sure we get this
on the record matt i'm really grateful
for you um as as in your character and
there's a man that would stand up and
defend me as a woman because we need to
recognize that women are
the weaker sex
wait wait wait wait wait wait
i had no idea that those guys i had no
idea that was coming i did not see this
that was the other reason i put her on
the or that i was thinking of her list
not only was it this whole like back and
forth what was the fact that she put she
doubled down in the whole like women
come from adam's rib god created us we
are weaker we are the weaker sex
meanwhile she's also the one who had two
affairs that we know of with a
polyamorous tantric sex guru and the
manager at the crossfit gym that she was
a part of so marjorie taylor green to
come in here i just want to go on a
small little rain right here
go ahead yeah marger taylor green to
come in again you know and try to talk
about you know the sanctity of marriage
and the role of a woman and the fact
that women are weaker you know she's
also the same woman that had two
separate affairs
open open affairs like people knew that
she was openly cheating on her husband
right and she was with a polyamorous
tantric sex scooper which is a mouthful
and also
the manager at the the crossfit gym that
she's a part of so marjorie taylor green
to come in here all righteous and and
christian like and women are are you
know are the the the result of adam's
rib from god who created us we are
weaker men are the superior race or or
or gender in this scenario
and so as a woman we have to serve them
much like i'm sure josh hawley really
wants you know barefoot in the kitchen
cooking making taking care of the kids
right margie taylor green's like you
know and they want their 12 year old
girls to serve to to be
to be uh servants to them as well as
child brides but here's the thing i
haven't seen i haven't seen anyone bring
up and you know i don't know if this is
the right take but i will say this
margery taylor green is claiming that
women are the weaker sex if women are
the weaker sex then why would she want
to be in congress right why wouldn't she
support a man right again i don't
believe that i don't know but using her
logic if women are the weaker sex then
why would she go against a man
who she did run against in the
congressional race for her district why
would she not want a man
to be in a role like that if women are
weaker then that would make me feel like
women aren't the appropriate people to
be in congress according to her logic
right well
here's i think here's what she's trying
she's trying to force feed
when someone says what's a woman the
weaker sex right that's the like that's
the yeah
and this is why they get confused
because she says the weaker sex right
she says that on purpose not the weaker
gender right the weaker sex because
these boneheads out there that's why
they're sexualizing kids gender because
gender the word gender and the word sex
in the dictionary they sort of share
a definition right they sort of share a
definition so they think because they
share a definition gender has to do with
sex sex has to do with gender so that's
why she's saying this stuff that's
that's the language that they're using
that's right
and and here's the thing like
women
you know
the fact that she would say women are
the weaker sex right okay let's let's
also keep in mind that women you know if
they're bearing children that's nine
around nine months maybe a little longer
depending if you're you know like uh
overdue but that's nine months of
carrying another thing in your body
right where you have to like you got
[ __ ] pain your arch is hurt your back
hurts you're irritable uh you you've got
uh you know stress emotional physical
problems going on
a woman has to deal with that for nine
or so months right
then you're like hey once i had this kid
now i have to raise this kid right i
gotta i gotta breastfeed i gotta be up
at all hours i gotta make sure that my
finances are in order i gotta make sure
that i have the support emotionally and
from my friends and family to help me
you know financially as well through
this situation then you know they grow
up a lot of stress right teenagers
whatever we've all been there like
that's not an easy job and that is not
an easy job for someone who's weak not
only that but you've got a woman who is
you know if she's a single parent she's
gotta you know work even harder right a
woman has to work just as hard well not
justice or has to work harder way harder
to to validate herself in just the world
right that's not even including the fact
that if you're a woman who is a person
of color right like we just saw this
through the whole scotus hearings right
we've got sexist misogynistic racist
things that happen through there so to
call women weaker
is is [ __ ] in my in my opinion
the fact that margera taylor green would
just say women are weaker
isis is [ __ ] [ __ ] right women are
i would say are much stronger than a lot
of men and we've talked about before
where women you know have to come in and
[ __ ] pick up the [ __ ] right right
they got despite the fact they don't
want to right they don't want to do that
they don't have to come in and do extra
work right like whether you're in a
relationship uh it's your parents your
mother you know whatever whatever yeah
right like women come in and have to
clean that up right they're the ones who
have to clean up because men thought
they could do it themselves you know
whether they're super inflated egos or
what have you they come in they [ __ ] it
up and then
women come in and they have to they have
to they have to fix it they have to
clean it up despite again despite the
fact that they don't want to they want
to just [ __ ] live their lives and do
what they want to do with equal footing
as men but they have to do their job and
they need to come and help support and
do a man's job right and then the man
goes i did that and i take all the
credit
so you've got a woman doing you know a
job and a half two jobs and then marger
taylor green over here with her own
privilege to say women are the weaker
sex and if that's true then you
shouldn't be in congress you should not
be running and representing the people
because obviously that's a harder job
and you know resign residing because a
man should be the one who's doing that
well
you know what i know
sex
you know i i think i think you're right
on the pregnancy thing that
um
they're really a woman is probably
that's the only reason why we exist as a
human race is because the women actually
carry uh they carry the babies because a
guy like matt gatz if he had to um oh
god if he had to carry a baby that guy
wouldn't last [ __ ] 30 goddamn days
[Music]
no shut the [ __ ] up like matt gates
is a piece of [ __ ] and is just
anyway i mean i i i i couldn't i
couldn't yeah okay i do want to call out
okay mj has been telling us to play the
stephen colbert club which we are going
to play here i got it right hilarious
what is this what is this clip set this
clip up everything everyone knows mj
especially where's him yeah so stephen
colbert is on uh on a set for his late
night show right uh with stephen colbert
i i want to note here mj's comment she
put a star see how she put the star in
it
i i told everyone earlier to put a star
if they want to uh
it's kind of like the signal so everyone
in the chat knows it's like a little
like a little hey hey pay attention to
me yeah yeah a little podcast
right so if you're talking to us yeah
and put a star in front of if you're
yeah that's thing that's a good idea
look at that innovation that's what we
do here we innovate so what's up
so the setup here is uh steven colbert
this is a pre-show moment right like
i've been i actually this isn't part of
the show this is no this is not part of
the show like i i've uh when i was in
new york years ago when letterman was
still um
uh when he was still
on the air i went to one of his tapings
um and there's a lot of fun right you've
got you know he comes out you know tell
some jokes uh gets to know the audience
and answer some questions right and it's
just kind of like a pre-show kind of
hype and this is that moment where
stephen colbert they're not filming uh
from what i understand this is before it
could have been also during a commercial
break but i doubt it if there was a
guess so i'm gonna say this is before
this is before the show before the show
starts he comes out and like warms up
warms up the degree right yeah gets him
laughing so he lets people ask questions
and they ask a question and this college
student asks a question
and i don't wanna i don't wanna talk
anymore about it because the question
then sets it up oh okay okay for uh by
the way mj thank you again for the super
sticker she said that's for the for
gabe's rant oh thank you yeah so thank
you so much
and see if anyone wants to get on the
super chat you can there thank you mj
for not only uh
calling out this clip but for the super
sticker let's play the clip and let's
see let's see what the question is i
think it's really light so if we can't
hear it i'll try to say it so yeah you
guys can hear
hey steven i'm a college student
my question is if you're if you had
donald trump on your show tonight what
would you ask him
crowd goes
uh well we're not broadcasting right now
so i'd say what does vladimir putin's
taste like
[Laughter]
now if you didn't hear if you didn't
hear keith stephen colbert may or may
not have said
um because he's not on the air
they're clearly not recording for the
show for for airing on tv they are
recording because we are watching the
video but he said what he would ask
donald trump what does vladimir putin's
dick taste like
you know which is um yeah
so let's watch the rest of the clip
a little ditty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't tell your grandkids that joke
and don't don't say that joke in front
of vladimir putin's wife because she may
come up and his wife well i don't i
don't know i don't know i mean i've
never seen i don't know i've only seen
it
i don't know i've only seen vlad on
horseback
i thought that was i thought that was
his wife
maybe i don't know i'm not really sure i
thought
and the fishing that was his wife i have
no idea i have no idea um you know
talking to vladimir putin about alpha
cucks like vladimir putin because
vladimir putin is an alpha cuck you know
he thinks he's he's got to be manly and
he i am alpha which if you have to say
you're out you're not alpha yeah you
know that um but we have a we have a
special alpha cuck this week can you can
you tell us who
representative tom leatherwood is and
why he got alpha cuck of the week yeah
yeah yeah so i just want to point out
also to anyone who's listening and
watching when i find these photos of
people i do a very i go i dig around to
find the the best and by best i mean the
worst photo right like we gotta really
represent who these people are on the
show
and tom leatherwood really came out of
nowhere uh because i i can only find
like three photos of him online right
he's a local he's a he's a
representative from tennessee but he
entered in with a with another woman um
this bill
that was the uh
what did we call it there's the mary
kidd bill that midas touch calls it it's
the pedophile bill it's the pedophile
the pedocon
uh republican kid diddler bill right
exactly they wanted little kids the
grand old pedophiles is what the gop is
now right so or or yeah you know go
ahead so so tom leatherwood over here
says hey you know what
we should make marrying people easier
and then everyone's like okay and he's
like and by easier i mean we shouldn't
have an age limit at all right people
should just be able to marry whoever
they want right because here's here's
kind of the thing that they're trying to
do right because the [ __ ] thing
about because they're trying to make it
to where it's like oh well it's because
we hate gay people is why we're doing
this bill it's kind of where they're
coming from right like they're like well
we have to have some sort of thing that
makes it look like we're hating someone
we're republicans so we definitely have
to discriminate and hate on someone so
that's like the direction of the bill
right right so what their what their
idea is and this is going to happen in
all states folks they're going
states are going to try to out tennessee
tennessee i'm sure florida will do what
texas do and then everyone will try to
out florida florida out texas texas
right missouri apparently already has
one on the slate that's going to go
through
since
the decision by the supreme court that
makes
marriage between uh two people of the
same gender if they want to get married
a state has to issue a marriage license
right
and because these uh pedo cons these
republican kid diddlers believe which is
all [ __ ] that marriage is sacred and
it's a sanctity of marriage and blah
blah blah they want to come up with an
alternative marriage which immediately
immediately you're like what the [ __ ]
attended a marriage because what they
want to do is they want to pretend like
they're boxing out lgbtq people from
this alternative marriage because
there's the old marriage which is now
now gay marriage and then there's this
new marriage which they
call like a common law type marriage
right but what they're doing what
they're doing is using this law by
making it look like it's anti-lgbtq
which their base is going to be uh
oh they're going to be happy about this
because it hates and discriminates
against people and that's what they love
they love that kind of [ __ ]
but what it does is it makes it to where
an old man can marry a little child a
little girl but let's listen here
because here is uh because the other
well the other thing too
on this build is the fact that
they say
uh people who are trans or gay or
whatever are groomers right right just
just another just just another objection
these people are groomers and we need to
protect them and the only way to protect
them is to marry them and by doing so we
need to groom these children right like
it's [ __ ] so gross it's [ __ ]
twisted in the logic
and and they're not gonna stop folks
this pedocon stuff they're not gonna
stop this so
because we started to yell and scream
and i'm gonna take credit for it because
we did a lot of yelling and screaming on
the show
and i did a lot of tweeting i put out a
lot of video and and i think it
pushed people to to say more outlandish
stuff about this bill because i think
that's one thing democrats are horrible
at they are so scared of saying the
outright truth and we [ __ ] don't do
not shy away from saying what is
actually happening and these are a bunch
of goddamn pedophiles trying to pass
state laws to make sure they can marry
little girls that is what they're trying
to do no matter how they try to dress it
up no matter how they try to spin it
but
here we go is a video
of
representatives in the state of
tennessee trying to push back on this um
let's listen in here is there no age
limit in this bill my understanding
now this this is tom leatherwood this is
the guy who's the applicant now he's
he's kind of the big proponent behind
the the bill is that right yep yeah yeah
him there's another woman as well but uh
he's the main he's the main face of uh
of this bill and it just happens that he
he's the main face of the bill and
if you look at tom leatherwood you would
um
you would really suspect i don't know
but right so when i when i said earlier
i was like oh i really try to do a good
job of finding you know really bad
photos of people i looked at his photo
and obviously there's only a few around
the internet because he's just not known
until this moment
but his photo in and of itself
looks like he
might be might be a pedicon yeah well i
think he is a pentagon let's listen
standing you know 18 is the way this
would be construed i just want to make
sure there wasn't an explicit agent in
my concern okay i'm sorry i didn't
understand he's like 18 is what we
construed to be strict age limits on
marriage
because let's let's let's back up a bit
because in tennessee the current
marriage law
is that a 17 year old can give consent
that is the current law um and this this
that wasn't young enough man wasn't
young enough well and and the way that
they're trying to get around this age
limit is not change that law what
they're trying to do is make a new way
of getting married
listen to that this is what they're
doing a new way
of getting married because the sanctity
of the other marriages lost and now
their religion forces them to have this
new way of getting married because
frankly they can't marry a 12 year old
girl with the old way of getting married
so now they got to invent a new way of
getting married right so let's listen in
tennessee and i don't think we want to
get away from that you're aware that our
current law does have an age limit yes
we're going to pass this bill out with
no age limit on here i would hope that
we would consider that and vote against
this bill we're making a whole bunch to
do in getting off on in the weeds here
age seven
this is this is another republican
saying we're getting off in the weeds
listen guys you guys are focusing on the
wrong details right okay the age thing
not a big deal no one's gonna try to
just uh i don't know take advantage of
this bill and marry someone younger and
then say well you guys pass it it's a
bill because here's the thing these guys
you would not bring it up if you
yourself did not have a desire to take
advantage
of that new passing of a bill right if
you
really if
like them being like oh you know what uh
if we really did feel this way then we
would put an age restriction on it
especially if we want to make it around
common law we want to box out lgbtq or
gay or whoever
uh
if age isn't a problem then you wouldn't
even touch it right or you would
redefine it for this common-law marriage
but the fact that you're saying there's
no age restriction honestly you can
marry as young as you want right like
the idea that they would even allow that
and then being like oh well you know i
didn't really think about it until now
[ __ ] that you thought about it when you
wrote it right when you redlined the age
out you yourself said yeah now 17's not
young enough gotta go younger gotta get
him when you're writing the bill and
you're like okay we're gonna make a new
kind of marriage right we're gonna make
a new kind of marriage because our
religion wants a new kind of marriage
right
how i you know marriage should be
between a man and a woman and let's
what's the age limit that we should have
on the you know what we're like well
most places would accept you know and uh
look at look at adults that's 18 or like
nope we're not doing 18. well we
currently have 17. no we're not doing
17. it's like what do you want he's like
no age yeah no age limit i you can't
abort babies but you sure as hell can
marry them yeah let's listen into what
this this republican bonehead continues
to say teen still applicable no sir that
applies to marriage licenses this
creates a different part this ability
does not come from a place of kindness
and understanding but rather a place of
prejudice and contempt the rhetoric
behind this bill implies that gay men
and women have devalued or tainted the
marriage process in tennessee a separate
registry religion as a guise to avoid
using the same licenses afforded to
same-sex couples the nicest word that
comes to mind is silly make no mistake
about it same-sex marriages the nicest
bothered feelings yeah that's the nicest
like that's like the filth that is like
filtered filtered filtered right you
respond to be like this is silly it's
like no it's god damn right it's
disgusting
but the other thing too is like these
these republicans like from the you know
the grand old pedophiles what they
really like
when you get married you have to pay for
a marriage license right you have to you
know
do the whole thing and you have to pay
in and do it right well you gotta you
gotta write it man write it down right
right but you know as a married couple
now you're paying taxes and doing this
and you got different benefits and stuff
like you yourself as a married couple
are paying more into the system
of that state
right or of that community so
the fact that they'd be like you know
what
we don't want as much money we don't
want as much this we don't want to like
by denying these people that they're
like you know what we will do we're a
rich old white man and i'm [ __ ]
real stingy with my money and i want to
get around it by doing a common
common-law marriage because i don't have
to pay for a marriage license i don't
have to do this i have to do that i just
got to groom that kid and it's cheap and
it's free you know that's the way that
they think about it that's the other
thing about this
is because this is called a common law
marriage right yeah yeah and if anyone
is familiar with states that have common
law marriage which a lot of states do
have a common law marriage and generally
what it means is if two people are
together for a very long period of time
and by together i mean they actually
have a relationship like a financial
relationship they own a house together
they own cars together they own bank
accounts together they own retirement
accounts together a lot of times the
state will will recognize them as a
common law marriage meaning
you're you're actually married you don't
know it we don't know it but you you are
married right
these [ __ ] gross old ass white men
want to have a common law marriage now
think about that that means that the
state doesn't know that they're married
to these children
they
have ownership yeah yeah with these
children right these children are common
law marriage with them right
that is the thing that they're trying to
do is trying to skirt that people would
even know that they're married to
children right
that's and it's the definition
of groomer and really honestly
up until
the last really the last year when
they've really tried to sexualize
children's gender they've really went
after
trans gender
children they went after lgbtq children
and children that have lgbtq parents
because they're going after those
parents as well
those children who ha who aren't who
aren't um in the lgbt community
themselves but their parents are right
they're going after those children as
well
it really i never heard the word groomer
much i never did i didn't understand
that because i i just i didn't know that
and a lot of people
even in my dm's have said this word has
been attached to the lgbt community for
a long time and let's finish let's
finish to see what dakota says here uh
because i think it's relevant is there
no basis for obstructing the equal
dignity we as lgbt people expect as
citizens of the greatest country in the
world may god continue to bless
tennessee frankly i feel kind of like
the tide has changed and if there's any
hostility it's against those people do
believe marriage comes from god and do
believe it's between one man and woman
they don't deserve the hostility they're
getting and if there's any lack of
kindness or understanding it's not on
the part of the people bringing this
jesus christ thank you what hostility i
have no idea is coming towards a
normative marriage that is
man and woman who is
who is attacking these people again
lgbtq
who you know same sex but like whoever
you are wherever you fall and whoever
your partners and wherever they fall
they don't give a flying [ __ ] what
another person who is a man and a woman
who has a just a normal marriage
has to they don't care they don't want
to go into your house they don't want to
tell you what to do they don't want to
tell you how to live your life they
don't know how to tell you how to how to
handle your relationship they're like
listen i'm in my own home this is my
[ __ ] domain i do my own [ __ ] i'm
happy with my partner i don't want to
have to deal with your [ __ ] and your
[ __ ] up christianity in the way that
you perceive marriage to be because it's
not one way it's a spectrum in terms of
how we all accept each other and how we
marry each other so the fact that these
people again the gop the grand old
pedophiles the grand old projectionist
is what they are right no [ __ ] they come
in here and they assume that other
people again we're the victim we're the
victim people are attacking us no
they're not no one [ __ ] cares about
you dude it's a fact that you have now
faded in to just irrelevant
just like in the sidelines that they're
like oh well we're not getting the
attention anymore people look at us look
at us we're the victim because these
other people these people who are
different than us these people who don't
accept the the normal man-woman
relationship
uh want to have something different
they're they're attacking the sanctity
of the marriage that was that was
developed in the bible right which again
the bible is [ __ ] a bunch of stories
by a by a bunch of random people making
[ __ ] up and about jesus who was a
goddamn grifter like let's just call
what it is right he was a homeless
magician on the street that was trying
to turn water into wine and doing these
tricks and you know
dude they were [ __ ] they're all
[ __ ] each other okay
okay let's just call it this in the
bible everyone was [ __ ] everyone okay
and that's that's the that's the that's
the king gay bible right there i'm
telling you how it really was everyone
in the bible was [ __ ] each other okay
they were [ __ ] going at it 24 7 and
what they wrote about was how people
they how they think people should be
so when i see
uh wait wait are you saying are you
saying the uh the disciples were
republican is that what you're saying
i'm saying i'm saying here's the thing i
also think that
the i think that the the the disciples
the 12 of them you know plus you know
judas who
then there was like 11 obviously but i
look at the 12 and i say nah dude
they're all [ __ ] right now the books
that they wrote i think they actually
wrote all the savage [ __ ] that they did
and then when eventually when the church
found these like manuals
you know what we need to do you know we
do the opposite this [ __ ] up right what
they did is they redlined every
[ __ ] thing in those in those
the book of the book of you know of luke
and everything they were just like nope
no this this [ __ ] was raunchy as [ __ ] we
need to get this out of here and they
then said you know what this is what
they actually said you know because it
was in another language it was in hebrew
or whatever you know um we need to
translate it into english and uh the way
that it actually translates because
here's the thing i would say there's
actual some true to this because it's
the way that they they changed uh um
homosexual right in the bible
uh i think it was pedophile or it was
something wrong that was translated and
they translated it to homosexual
and it's that type of just like liberal
translation they made in there makes me
think that when it was jesus was around
before and after [ __ ] was crazy
it was wild and what they wrote about
and what they transcribed it to be was
not actually what it was it might have
been some prude over here in his house
and his dwelling with
what he thought his wife or some [ __ ]
in-cell right they're like it should be
like this
and so when you see these people like
leatherwood
they're just projecting what they
what they feel like everyone should be
right and again it's it comes from a
place internally which is an insecurity
or or lack of confidence or or the fact
that they just can't be who they truly
are then they
have to then map this on to other people
and this example of him trying to pass
this bill where he goes you know what
we should let anyone marry anyone of any
age and everyone's like yo yo yo uh we
already have an age right right
like why would you need to redefine this
he goes well i never thought it would
anyone would take advantage of this and
i i never thought that that someone
would would say oh well i could marry a
kid i mean meanwhile
really thinking he's like after this is
done i'm going to get myself a second
and third wife and the other part of
this too is the fact that
um
you look at when you're like filing
taxes right you're like oh i have a
dependent i have to i have to claim a
dependent i don't even know how that
[ __ ] works like you have the parents
who go yep you're now under this
household and this random old white dude
says this girl is now mine and i have to
like i don't know exactly how that works
i'm not an accountant and i'm not a
[ __ ] pedophile but these people are
trying to slip through the cracks and
take advantage of loopholes so that they
can just live their lives their best
lives right right a bunch of these rando
pedo cons right
it's insane and so when i see this [ __ ]
i'm just like you guys are [ __ ]
disgusted and gross and vile and i'm
glad that other people on the on on this
committee that were listening were like
yo are are we really this is this is
[ __ ] up right and they got and this is
just tuesday are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
this is insane
this is nuts and then you've got the guy
who again he's like in the nicest way
possible again is [ __ ] filter filter
filter filter filter filtered all the
way down to silly it's silly it's silly
it's ridiculous so so uh thank you um
tom leatherwood for i guess thank you
for uh joining the awful cooks his face
does look like leather like it's just
like whoosh that's the other thing too
is this creep's name is leatherwood oh
yeah i can't make it it sounds like a
villain's name right like a like a like
a like a white guy who you're like who
in this town killed someone right
leatherwood
and you're like leatherwood and he
didn't even kill one person he's got 30
bodies in the basement right no like
that's a type of and he tried to marry
every single one of them it's really
even they said no and he was like you'll
be my forever bride right that's common
law gives me the ability to marry tom
leatherwood if he doesn't get his way he
will make forever brides i guarantee it
that's the type of guy that he is oh my
god well
our winner of the week uh marjorie
taylor green there's several reasons we
already discussed one reason why but i i
want to play
um a video but before that let's give
her her due here for her win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
marjorie taylor green wins again
bonehead of the week i do want to play
because we know
she thinks um
people are pro pedophile she's
projecting uh her her the petticon
republican kit diddler ways but there is
one other thing that she was projecting
here and she tried to do this thing
where she
uh went uh
after jamie raskin on the floor of the
house and he was having none of it let's
listen to what his response was to
marjorie taylor again let's listen
the general lady i think said something
about the russian hoax or uh russian
collusion i accept the heckling mr
speaker that that's all right
because if she wants to continue to
stand with vladimir putin and his brutal
bloody invasion against the people of
ukraine she is free to do so and we
understand there is a strong
trump putin axis in the general ladies
party she wants to continue to stand
with vladimir putin donald trump that is
her prerogative but please do it on your
own time
fourth win
he fourth whisper what the he fourth
with no one says that no one says no
no listen
when you can out saki
uh jinsaki you are [ __ ] you are in
the hall of fame of slam dunks and
dunking these pro-putin petticons into
the [ __ ] trash that was absolutely
and he's done this like i don't know
four or five times this last week yeah
he's absolutely bald these little these
pedicons up into like little dry boogers
and flick them all the way across the
room it is crazy it is crazy that they
would even attempt
attempt to go after jamie raskin and we
need more of this absolutely more of
this more yes i don't think he i think
he personally takes like any anything
that marcia taylor green has to say i
think it personally takes offense to it
because his role in the capitals uh in
the january 6 capital uh you know uh uh
impeachment hearings right towards
donald trump he was up there he made a
great case and then you got people
obviously like margaret taylor green
here like me it was not a real thing it
was not an insurrection and he's like
[ __ ] you man i looked at hours of
footage and i have [ __ ] i was there
he was there he was [ __ ] there it's
it's incredible um so thank you marjorie
taylor green for coming in um at the
very beginning and all the way through
the poll winning bonehead of the week
join us every single week on friday in
the second hour the tony michaels
podcast bonehead of the week and go
download it on apple spotify and google
and also follow us on the mighty touch
facebook page youtube twitter twitch
that is bone end of the week thank you
very much we'll be right back after the
song
[Music]
[Applause]
all right all right all right gabe i
think you gotta jump don't you you gotta
jump okay thanks for bone end of the
week and all the graphics um maybe next
week we'll have yeah we'll we'll have
the new one we'll have the new banner up
there okay good good good thank you very
much gabe we'll talk to you soon here we
are over time we are over time today but
i do want to give a few announcements
before we leave again we broadcast live
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central youtube twitter twitch go follow
us at tony michael's pod for the
bonehead of the week poll so you can get
your vote in on the bonus of the week
and we break it down every single friday
in the second hour bone end of the week
we're also live on the midas touch
facebook page because we are proud
partners of minus touch so go follow us
there go to thetonymichaels.com find all
the places you can listen to us whether
it be youtube twitter twitch the minus
touch facebook page or your favorite
podcast directory
you uh excuse me
apple spotify google wherever you find
your podcast give us a good review
and really until next week monday folks
noon eastern 11 central right here on
youtube twitter twitch surf's up
[ __ ] have a good weekend
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking